well I the tunnel grew colder me Leah
and I were close to the surface now son
would climb up into the howling wind to
fight our way through whatever
nightmares were waiting there my long
journey was nearly at the end but would
have the courage they will to see it
through hey job when you left your home
station the other thing will end up in a
place like this not knowing whether we
were about to save our world or 7-string
birthday they say
all right what I have to get through the
military outpost yeah she could you do
to her something's moving in the next
room or the new v8 I'll cover ya get a
pressed buttons she's my guess is gonna
hold it use the acuity hand system to
open the game and I can doing that and I
guess I'll jump check those crates for
that boy okay Sam this before hey Jeff
soon follow me you missin ya climb
operate you know it's conquer game ready
yes me get [ __ ] okay
up we go [ __ ] okay at Frank's place
mm-hmm seems like nobody's home before
we the surface put your gas mask or
without you could be like hey Sadie
school I can that's a some S&M [ __ ] okay
mean is there this is literally a few
mins many little Sofia get 11
you
asia
look like this gambit each community
open the door please need easy change
game I said Sunday trying again
damn whoo damn
clear let it out maybe the weather down
that's affirmative we've made contact
they should be under seal until the
tower now Roger get a fix a modification
then it's crazy because this is not like
two different from Russia like how it is
now you know
you see him
Jamie [ __ ]
what maybe Im system in the line
in person
ah
in each
the game as you know it ends life was
never easy in the tunnels but it was our
home there was comfort in his routines
in seeing the same people day after day
but since the mutant attacks had
escalated fear all the station I had
just turned 20 and could never have
imagined what would follow in the
morning that my stepfather's friend
hunter arrived at the barricade
the [ __ ] goes
what happens in there
am I in a row
you
that's cute artyom waked last I see
hunters on his way in he should have
news from the other stations come on
check oh cool yeah actually interact
with stuff graphics you're nice
developers are see just a gay let's go
on to peace disease I've been through
worse 911 what's your blue Alex yes
Nikolai station can't survive much
longer if these attacks won't stop we
must do something and I got a brother
another patrol everybody my brother is
in hospital The Situation's under doctor
hasn't said anything so terrible what
about Alexei he was at the outpost
examples many want to leave the stage
side poopies elastic half life
let's go our team The Situation's under
control click on name oh no visitors
theatre hey Sarah tell me anything I
don't know what Tom not you they said no
cops this was the third time come on
Alex skull or jump
how are the wounded not much improvement
to die this morning the dark ones do not
kill outright sooner or later this leads
to death okay okay we are here to
generate can't reach what the hell would
that be it's hunter Mills doll knock
first open the damn gate I heard this
game not the jerk is like that suppose
like supposedly are sinners welcome to
exhibition hunter Thanks now closer get
it's been a long time under
good to see you Alex hello Artie aha
that's a hunter what's happening in the
outside world these days God much God
most of what i hears about the
exhibition and the undead infesting your
tunnels hmm Artyom I metatrader selling
or postcards of New York City I thought
of your wall the gays are not the usual
mutant creatures this is something else
something much worse dark ones well
whatever inhale they are my order has a
motto if it's our style you'll kill it
just what we need it there are wounded
here just behind the wall the whole
eagle take your group to the tunnels we
must stay here and defend the hall all
right our team boy okay
where'd I get weapon Oh Jim get the
weapon oh the hell this [ __ ] the [ __ ]
rusty be a metal they never come this
far into this station it's the hospital
they smell the blood okay
all right i got my a six-step a holden
like a little girl
that's all
hi guys
go to the bathroom
it's hopeless
you
[ __ ] it hey the [ __ ] us but my
lighter sure of course he thought that I
shot this one turned on right now no
dark ones here just as usual tunnel
trash even when you don't see them the
dark ones are their fear that's their
weapon that's what made the no solace
has run through the tunnels like rats
the dark ones are not simple mutants
they're homo Novus the next step in
evolution you've heard about survival of
the fittest guess what we lost the
[ __ ] impossible odds happen to you
Alex you can go like lambs to the
slaughter I'll hang on to whatever life
I got with teeth and claws and I'll take
more than a few of your homo Novis with
me to hell you think you're some old
movie cowboy have a look under ten
soldiers trained in combat but he's
broken their minds God the dark ones
they destroy the outer guards box
still racism president the year twenty
thirty three
damn damn damn
the devil knows what's happening out
there beyond your perimeter I must go
recon the situation listen carefully at
him if I'm not back here by morning you
must get to Paula station and find a man
named Miller tell him what's happened to
me it's stirring in the northern tunnels
show this to Miller so he knows I've
sent you I trust everything to you I
tira don't let me down okay yoga now if
we are to survive this threat must be
eliminated no matter the cost eliminated
understand meanwhile Harding's fine
Hunter did not return it wouldn't be
easy to find an excuse to leave the
station and travel to polis but I had
given my world I learned that the car
one was heading to Riga the next day and
needed guards assigned on for the right
to GTA colusa can dr. Nash Minotaur
mazha finally taking your time as usual
ah alright grab your gear go to the
platform they're waiting for us I'll
meet you there hey chump don't forget
anything huh flashlight wats da spirits
impoverished and aroma what's the spirit
of the coach is kaput
ok
you're homeless scrubs situation
that's some nice music where did you get
that back I'm some soap water and says
everywhere just lucky you'll be what you
say [ __ ] and is open it yourself I'm not
marries a girl go find the keys you know
I can't get up idiot absolutely ok can I
get a funny little sparking about thur
in walking around and reading those two
footprints everywhere hey giving a dime
Jesus let me get some rest with you I'm
thinking my word sorry get lost I John
most importantly the northern cali will
now be secure find are sometimes
military units in major step in defense
of the metro system as a sign of good
will that not only I'll are already on
our way here we're choosing all all
citizens to welcome a reason slice and
2000's please make sure to our
can you fight
excellent shirts definitely better than
yours the best gown in the world usual
time how much did you say you spurt
definitely better anyway she needs a
rope to the belt of the rear guard drunk
again who's your you so go to the armory
no idea you need some weapons okay let's
take a look man it's you submachine gun
5.45 caliber made in the armory it's got
poor accuracy and overheats like hell
that's why they call it a bastard use
short bursts RPM on the head help
yourself to some ammo too here's a
universal charger to keep the battery
power integra and a gas mask put it on
if you crossed any radiation hot zones
Lori god help you go up to army issue
first aid kits just in case Thank brah
okay you're supplying my friend feel
free to try out your weapon on my firing
range in that you try not to stick out
your head too much okay
right
it's a special
get the fullest
new demo asked me
thanks a deal okay selling my
singapore's all of us
color doing well I presume not bad at
least read this [ __ ] language
[ __ ] you my saucy guy
yeah that's how it is I've been caught
the man's supposed to make a living son
okay [ __ ]
watch it on her own [ __ ] way I see oh
stop it I'm busy ma'am ma'am
nobody home we're all [ __ ] away I
gotta go back to it was
they said there's a [ __ ] map but
there's not a [ __ ] man
Aaron folly field weapons make good
Sanders
hello do you think one day we will go
back up to the surface I never seen the
hostages those pictures
come in son you're ready to set off the
circuit good you've probably heard that
our station is creating an alliance with
ria we're sending them a couple of rail
cars with humanitarian hoods some
weapons and some miscellaneous gear it's
the cargo you'll be looking after it's
not a business / should not be too hard
you know it's music as much green eyes
Artyom you one thing before you go I put
your situation up to huh just like
they're reckless even violent by nature
there's nothing to be gained further
you're here ah I aren't you about the
big load how about helping us abdomen
all right there was a joke I know it's
not your job that's your time here here
move previous so you're ready to move
out yeah are you ready let's go this
camera
fortunately know that
[ __ ] is that you take that seat a tomb
and your Eugene take this one more piece
would anybody forget anything so uh you
get your gift let's go of it hey guys
going to Riga yeah we are can I get a
lift sure but no free rides you'll have
to pull the lever sometimes I can do
that let's go then
alrighty then good luck to everyone
staying home and to us too what let's go
good luck to us so are you ready to
finally be somewhere else whoa yoga free
at last huh well for as long as the ride
takes any way to be far more dangerous
even the right it was the first time it
had left the safety of my home station
it troubled me that I hadn't told my
stepfather the truth I would not be
heading straight back from Riga but
hunter was depending on me so were you
from Riga making the rounds buying
merchandise well bet you've seen a few
places then yeah the market doesn't I
got your ego and met the pig matter
already I used to make regular trips to
police but getting there now requires a
lot of luck that were being from massive
dream okay my hands are connected to the
whole metro and carry a lot of stations
but doesn't welcome outsiders and if
it's not answer then you have to go
through the Reds the Nazis or your
regular bandit and these guys are really
going at it lately if they're not
fighting everyone else their warring
with each other Peter what's up military
Caravan got stuck near Alex a scare a
tunnel collapse rudder [ __ ] you have to
use the service tunnel bypassing galaxy
s day [ __ ] stomach all right Peter open
up again okay no point being stuck here
forever why well what's wrong with the
tunnel well it's an ordinary Donald not
too slowly maybe I went through that
last month and wow I just don't like it
that's all okay
so we're now looking
Orcs led the way
Ellis safety we're writing a ham card
underwear are so I think we'll make it
there ok
[ __ ] just get ripped my fellows get mom
damn if you help push the lever we'll
get there sooner okay Eugene's you go
help them in who should move faster here
you watch the back onto sure I'll help
to regain no now get out of here sooner
it's scary when they're around and I
pity them damn good luck is that and you
hear them reap will do you meet them
what are you talking about that but what
the hell is going on but what buddy boy
what's that sling to me oh my head that
you apply
right exactly what we
oh great I know where this goes I can
waken up by the toilet pool the wedding
knows our gym over here if we are to
survive this is that must be eliminated
no matter the cost eliminated this eight
days later or is this present as person
the [ __ ] is that typical Hollywood
running fanatic they like a yoga Moodle
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I know I
Lexi any [ __ ] doesn't
for him
save the day of guns okay
wake up sorry sir
what the hell's going on [ __ ] wake up
people people wake up what I sake what
is what is wake up
that Jesus I can't
[ __ ] dark notempty mr john concep TMO
try don't try to
we're almost at the roadblock just come
on
central
oh [ __ ] that I'm [ __ ] die is that
scripted ah that was hot I need week
yeah that's hair did
you